okay everybody
what's up
earlier today Stanley sassed me and Toby
gave me some suggestions on how to
discipline him they did not work
obviously because they were stupid so I
am now going to fake fire him
what does that mean it's like a mock
execution
yes it is a good idea it's the only
possible solution I have left well you
can actually fire him no okay
why are you telling us this because I
want you to behave as if I'm actually
firing him Oscar okay Michael if you
hadn't told us this then we would have
thought that you were actually firing
I'm not firing him I'm not I will need
you to act like I am firing him just
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pretend that I'm firing him and I need
you to act like I am firing him do you
get that do you get it I'm teaching him
a lesson he needs to learn humility all
right that's all I'm okay here he comes
let's just
Play Act
Stanley may I talk to you for a second
Stanley Hudson
you are fired
are you serious
I am serious we are all serious
you are fired like a heart attack Dwight
has been acting manager for three months
now
a week just feels like three months
Let's see we all have to punch into a
Time Clock which is very old very strong
and has the slot about the size of a
finger
we were all given new business cards big
enough to set us apart from the
competition which is how I learned that
our titles are all now Junior employee
our lunch breaks are staggered to
prevent wasting time
mine's a 10 30 and I find that the first
hour of the day goes by a lot quicker
than the second seven hours stop
stalling
come on
It's a beautiful morning at Dunder
Mifflin
as I like to call it great Bratton keep
it running
do I love being manager
I love my kids I love real estate I love
Ceramics I love my job I love wrestling
find out what language this is
probably care
cloth near my style of Emerson
okay team building on this side of the
room Stanley Phyllis Jim Ted Elroy and
this side of the room Pam Meredith
Phyllis Creed
you never called a meeting
Bo body Bo body what is the first b
stand for
what are we doing we're making acronyms
okay what does the first b stand for
um business I like it
business good Kevin all right Theo
we need a new manager
Michael can I
okay I'm just gonna skip right past the
what and go with why because this is the
recreation of that crime scene I'm the
dead body and these are my brain chunks
hey shut up you're dead Michael can I
talk to you no Michael here
shut up they need this game Jim
let us have this stupid little game all
right
oh you startled me my stars my heart
nearly left out of my chest what can I
do you fall Alice is on the phone he's
returning your call detective Wallace I
don't think so I think it's David
Wallace from Denver Mifflin oh shucks
tell him I'm not here you're not gonna
answer the phone no I only answer to
detective Wallace because I got a warm
body in the other room
I'll take it hey David
what's the news
nothing yet
well I guess that's not well there is
some bad news
there has been another murder
a murderer you say
I do declare you getting psyched up yeah
Andy nobody really expects you to go
through it Tunes
what am I doing here
why did Robert pick me
confession I don't know what I'm doing
I mean do you like it
you having fun
I'll tell you this everybody else is
having a lot of fun
and you did that
my ass is only so big I mean I can't do
this every day but I think it's big
enough to buy you some time until your
next great idea
which by the way I can't wait for
no one expects me to go through with
this right absolutely not
well that's Ink My stink
[Applause]
do your worst
[Music]
we've got prizes 10 bucks candy bar
manager for an hour but there are also
penalties like no internet Stanley gets
your lunch
so I thought we could take the customers
and
maybe we could
you realize you're not actually talking
to me right
and hey Kelly
Charles you wanted me oh no I'm in I'm
in bed Kelly
the new receptionist is also named Kelly
so Kelly Kapoor has decided to hover
around my desk so that she can run into
Charles's office every time he calls for
Kelly
she thinks that if she says you wanted
me enough he will in fact want her
it's not the worst flange he's ever had
Owen Kelly yes Charles yes he wanted me
I'm gonna call you Kapoor okay and you
Hannah
if we're changing names can I be Aaron
it's my middle name and okay that's very
pretty
well you know my middle name is rajini
Ganda and I hate it I hate it so Pamela
I'm going to start this review not by
telling you what you lack but rather
asking you what it is you want really
okay well
um
I like consistency in the manager's
position no weird silent coups stuff
like that I'm easy that's not really
what you want what you want is a good
night's sleep working mother of two
whoa that's kind of condescending would
you say something like that to Jim does
Jim have to breastfeed did Jim carry
around those babies for what is it 12
months be honest does Jim really get up
in the night well I mean the only reason
he doesn't is because I'm breastfeeding
and Philip doesn't like a bottle you
must be
fancy a nap
no go on
lie down right here
there's a blanket in here
I used it earlier myself
dreamed I could breathe underwater like
Jacques Cousteau
no one will know
I'll wake you up
when you wake up
you will earn more money
I think
you're a witch
I think you're amazing
you know that right
go on say it I'm amazing
I'm amazing
all right there you go it seems a little
close you sure that's a real foul line
15 feet from the Baseline so if you need
me to move it in no that's 15.
okay and uh you know what to make it
interesting Jordan why don't you sit
underneath the basket seriously yeah
come on I'll dunk over you best seat in
the house I don't think I can do that
I'm holding your jewelry yeah
okay fair enough Kevin you do it yes
what are you okay here
someone want to sit in Kevin's lap
Angela no Oscar no thank you okay Jimmy
this is for you to show you that
anything is possible fantastic all right
yep it's also for the troops
Doctor Is In
the search committee finally decided
after a lot of deliberation on Robert
California for the manager position
who took one look around and left
all right